[Music]
a hi ni St to you are your nails painted
yeah I love that can I see nice thank
you um so I know we don't have much time
so I was wondering if I could try
something new sure
so uh we don't have much time s i just
um but
[Music]
stuff so I was just really
wondering
pegging I'm actually curious ladies
ladies when you see a dude and he got
like pink fingernails y'all into that
[__] I'm part of an East African
religion straight out of Ethiopia
straight out of Ethiopia
Ethiopia no
bro n n bro n we not all about to hold
this
[Music]
[Laughter]
L
you
where you going [__] why
you why you leaving
[__]
no why you
leave oh [__] oh godamn so I was
wondering if I could try something new
sure so I'm part of an East African
religion straight up out of Ethiopia
suan suan yeah tell us
more you know it's crazy what's crazy I
don't believe this guy's Ethiopian at
all no no he's part of a religion
straight out of out of that means he
is and I was wondering if I could recite
like a sucin um prayer for
[Laughter]
you okay awesome so if you close your
eyes
[Music]
I think he's
trolling I think he's trolling that
that's the best troll ever I think he's
trolling hit the button right in the
middle of his
prayer
yeah and that was it yeah and what's
your name Jay jayen J nice to meet you
nice to meet you
too yeah it's
okay why did you press the button when
you see the button it's like oh crap I
got to press it I yeah sorry it was nice
meeting you nice meet you too wait you
press me because you couldn't help
yourself I just really wanted to press
it even though
butt you the butt the
left you know what he gave you the Vibes
of why'd you press it I hope
so oh my God he just really want to
pressing I'm Isaiah Elena nice to meet
you nice to meet you too Isaiah has
produced over six albums he's a rapper
oh God can you ever hear your R A little
I I don't know if I want to do the first
the first bar is I'm a [__] and so
uh I'm kind of curious now oh God
okay I'm a [__] I'm a nuisance I'm
so great at not really choosing what I'm
supposed to be and what I'm doing it's I
am by okay it's more of a recent
development like I feel like I've always
been this way but not as um accepted in
the midwest to be anything other than
straight so that's really it's a great
place
for I just no no no that's a violation
bro she's talking about I'm by and I
just never been able to express myself
and never be really accepted but now I
feel accepted that's fantastic
rejected rejected all you feel
acceptance let's fix that [__] no
bisexuals for me today anyone who just
heard that verse has to
go oh fair
enough I'm Isaiah nice to meet you I'm
nice to meet you too what are you do
looking for right now in a relationship
I'm mostly just trying to meet new
people and you know if something
develops that's great what about you
I've had my time with like casual dating
and I'm ready to find something maybe a
little more
serious sorry have a good day Skyler
Skyler I'm El Leaf I like your Flamingo
shirt oh thank you yeah does it glowin
the dark sometimes it does yeah cool I
like your haircut thanks it's kind of
new so I'm still like getting used to it
that's cool thank
[Music]
you I'm getting used to it it's not that
cool not a big Star Trek fan bye oh wow
listen she do got that she do got that
Commander spot no I appreciate it I
appreciate that reference yeah you can
do it yeah of course I can oh right
there all right there Spock I'm Skyler
Ashley Ashley what are you looking for
in a relationship I guess you can say
I'm looking to like settle down with
somebody but like I'm going with the
flow I'm not in a rush to get that what
about you I think I'm looking to
experiment with different types of
relationships my friend has a term
called relational Anarchy that I'm like
I think is kind of cool [__] boy she
wants to settle down he's talking about
Anarchy Anarchy in in relation [__] boy
an sounds like a way of like I think one
day I might just want to walk out on my
kids and wife
that's Anarchy I'm prettyy sure being a
dead beat is anarchy are you
still hey you know what at least we're
on
it that's awkward two people who want to
reject each other tried to reject each
other and failed they got to sit at the
table that's this is my kind of this is
my kind of show
yeah dang I need CCH up no it's good
it's nice meeting you yeah so scary oh
Christ it's 6 o00 uh-huh I don't have
any more time everybody has to go home
if you were to start a podcast what
would the theme be maybe about like
photography I've been really into
photography lately oh yeah so yeah what
about you what's uh what would the
podcast be I read a lot okay um a lot of
smut a lot of smut is that what you said
mhm a lot of smut M enlighten
me
no carry on yeah yeah we're going to
keep this one in the bank I'm fine well
she's about to tell you I'm fine she
tells you me I cuz I don't
know what's
SM so it's just like very um graphic you
know just sexual yeah books that's the
thing only woman can s not look
creepy yeah I'm into this
mud automatically creepy what's mut oh
um very graphic
novels
automatically sorry that's okay you seem
I think we're just like different okay
both of y'all don't like each other all
right don't have to explain it don't try
[Music]
to no [__] that [__] Renard J J how's it
going for you today good
I'm I'm doing great dude I'm living my
best life right now she's not into him
either thought I'm like this guy sounds
like he's on drugs yeah he sound like he
took some speed or something cuz this
man I'm living my best life he just seen
[__] race cars and spaceship flying
behind you I've done that ony
psychedelics before like you're talk
that's what that's what you see really
when you on psychedelics
yeah I see a lot of things I see a lot
of things I'm not going get into those
but you can you decipher what's real and
what's not if I mentally Focus yes but
sometimes it's almost like your cous
just take a backseat and you're so
caught up in whatever you li yeah yeah
it's like when you getting swept up in a
wave you ever been swept up in a big old
wave you not thinking you like you don't
have time to think that's what s does
feel like sometimes it feels like my
brain's melting into something else so
you asking me do I know it's real I'm
like if I focus but then if I stop I'm
like yeah this where we want to be [__]
back on the Cho choo train that's all I
I don't want to know I don't want to
know what's true but yeah if I have to I
do I'm hanging out with the boys in the
back you know I get to talk to gorgeous
women and and we're getting paid for
this great you sound like a SP
spokesperson he's having a good time you
don't like people having a good time no
bro I'm having a good time you're not
having a good time bro I'm having the
best time with the boys we out here
talking on the camera sharing our
[__] thoughts just having that cool
little Banner with the boys with the
people you're not having a good time I'm
having so much fun yo smile I'm smiling
let's go let's get it you you watch it
smile yeah all right what are the two of
you looking for right now I definitely
was someone that was ready to get
married but I don't believe in marriage
so you don't believe in marriage why why
is that I just don't think it's
necessary okay all that was it for
today I'm going to say Seattle got some
weird people the people theyd be
bringing on these shows are [__]
weird he a relationship Anarchist get
get him the [__] up out of here that's
that's like a that's a kucho way to say
[__] boy yeah that was wild this whole
episode was wild I'm just glad his
Ethiopians didn't get slandered cuz he
sound like he made that [__] up he's not
Ethiopian y there some people be
claiming countries they never even
visited and I'd be stressed out looking
at it's a religion that is Ethiopian
yeah and he didn't look Ethiopian too
you you you never you never you never
heard about
zukan listen this sound like one of them
uh you know tribal sh not tab type
things I could be wrong someone might
educate me but as far as I know Ethiopia
got a lot of major religions and I never
heard of sukhan on that list but you
know the thing with African tribalism is
that there's so many small little
there's lot of tribes so you could
probably find find some reference to it
but it's not a major ReliOn didn't
happen is that if it's not a major
religion how do you out of Seattle like
yeah I practiced it it's like you know
that's kind of weird where it's
something so Niche to one part of a
country and they have that relation
because of their environment and stuff
like that and you decide out of like on
the other side of the world to practice
it out of it feels like some dude in
Russia was like I'm a Navajo like what
no you're not Navajo no you're not you
are not a Navajo you're not a Navajo
Navajo maybe but not
Navajo Fu listen we got rosarians we got
Jewish people we got Protestants we got
Orthodox we got a large population of
Muslims we got Jews in the north we got
everything I never heard of no sukhan
but someone might educate me again
there's so many different tribes you
never know but it seemed like a bit of a
gimmick to me